hi everyone it's Jerry I have a round
seven game to share with you from the
ongoing
World rapid Chess Championship 2022 on
the white end Daniel dubov and he's
playing against nihal sarin
this is a surprisingly quick defeat of
sarin only an 18 mover
and it comes out of a Queen's Gambit
accepted
I found this one instructive there's a
nice
attacking idea that I took away from
this one
the early going the first eight moves
nothing special whites regaining the
pawn meanwhile black is expanding on the
queen side
it's White's reaction to this last move
that gave me pause
so I'll throw this one to you as a pop
quiz what would be your reply to Black's
last move
feel free to pause the video
okay
the move played in the game is not to
take with the E Pawn
or the Knight on D4 instead look to
activate the queen Rook dubov one of the
more creative
Minds in the game
he wants to activate the rook and it is
certainly activated in this game after B
takes a rook takes a
we're just a move or two away from the
queen Rook playing a very active role on
the king side
now I want to point out that
as black you could consider
not allowing white to activate the Rook
you could consider playing B4
The Rook will not be activated on the a
file so fast but do know A4 has still
gained something
primarily the softening up of the C4
square a point
that the queen Knight will look to make
use of
in just a couple moves
okay in this game it's B takes a rook
takes a straight away
and now D4 has hit three times
computer suggests taking on E3
and white will be playing this position
as a Gambit
black doesn't go for the pawn though
instead puts an emphasis on development
Bishop to E7 is played
what is maybe a reason or two
um to decline the offer of a pawn
the reason or two to not play this move
um I think it may be related to
on one hand
The Black Queen not being so comfortable
with finding a stable Square on the
queen side
you note the bishop watches directly
over the B6 Square now this B6 square is
one of the few remaining
for the black queen who is soon to find
it
kind of tricky to find a stable Square
on the queen side we have both Rooks
soon to be doing something on the queen
side both Bishops pointing towards the
queen side and additionally
with they're no longer being a white
Pawn on E3
this bishop is also pointing toward has
a clear Lane a clear diagonal towards
the king's side so
if you know one day the move H6 is
necessary to be defending
against a bishop in Rook combined or
coordinating on H7 you're probably
asking for some sacrifice
in any event two Bishops on these two
squares open diagonals they
are beautiful pointing at both sectors
okay in the game
Bishop E7 Rook takes D4 Queen B6 you
could breathe
for at least a move she won't be
bothered on B6
Knight D2 Knight B to D2 Knight C6 Rook
is hit Rook H4
and from here we have Bishop to B7 so
one of the better
continuations in the computer's eyes is
to not develop the bishop but instead
play
A5
the idea to eliminate one of the
two very aggressive white pieces
Bishop A6 right around the corner
okay in the game it's Bishop to B7
Knight C4 Queen C7
and white is now inviting the last piece
one of the last pieces
Queen Bishop King Rook not yet playing
side Castle Bishop C3
two open diagonals towards the king
White had to work a little bit harder to
get this bishop activated
but it's there pointing however in
direct at the heart of Black's King side
and from here we have G6
considered a better defense on the
king's side at this point a better
defense of the threat Bishop takes
Knight and then Bishop takes H7 is to
play H6 doesn't create any holes
on the king's side
either way it's probably going to be
tricky however you slice it trying to
defend this
the move played in the game is G6
and now we have Knight to G5
so one of the ideas here if we make a
move such as Rook to d8 in this position
white has these tricks to take on H7
a couple times black can't take the Rook
now
because it would lead to Queen H5 we get
to see the power of these Bishops taking
advantage of the pinned Pawn
with mate to follow in the corner pocket
that's just one of the ideas that white
has in mind
okay the reaction to Knight to G5
turns out to be a big blunder
considered best here by black is to play
E5 to try and at least tame this bishop
so you're not seeing these these uh dark
squares
okay the move play in the game is Knight
to D5 and we're just one move out
and Sauron resigns so I'll throw this
two as a pop quiz white to move would a
dubov play that had sarin resigning here
okay here we go
Queen H5 a very
flashy finish to this one
there's now no defense it's a Checkmate
in four
H7
is under Fire three times and if you
take the queen it's a main one
with these three minor pieces
brutal brutal finish something that he
just completely overlooked so
a very interesting game again my main
takeaway was this quick activation
of The Rook first playing A4
and then pivoting there swinging over
and we have this
you know
Queen Rook playing at
a very active role in an attack on the
king's side so
anyhow let's have a quick look at the
tail of the tape on this one we could
see just how smooth this one went for
team dubov
pretty smooth there
96 accuracy
no inaccuracies mistakes or blunders
and just the one big blunder there by
sarin an interesting attacking idea from
this 18 mover a quick little lesson in
attacking play with this game
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye